das ist wirklich eine ziemliche
sensation zum ersten mal wurde ein film
in bakterien gespeichert dabei ist das
kein verrücktes frankenstein experiment
denn das erbgut von bakterienzellen
lebewesen also deren dna eignet sich
hervorragend als speichermedium in einem
gramm könnten unfassliche 400
milliarden gigabyte gespeichert werden
beginnt jetzt die speicher revolution
oder sind die gefahren dieser gentechnik
viel zu groß jetzt wirklich 5000
fiction herzlich willkommen ach was gab
es alles verrücktes bisher
holografische speicher magnet bleiben
speicher tesafilm und und und wie
können möglichst viele daten
möglichst lange möglichst schnell auf
möglichst kleinem raum gespeichert
werden
es ist eine der zentralen fragen der
menschheit die mit buchdruck
schallplatte loch karte magnetbahn
festplatte ssd laufwerk immer besser
gelöst werden doch die suche hört
nicht auf jetzt ist man beim erbgut
angelangt zunächst der dna von
bakterien dem des darmbakteriums
escherichia coli
vielen dank für den themenvorschlag an
dürfen frei ermöglicht wird das durch
ein werkzeug das vor knapp fünf jahren
in der gentechnik vorgestellt wurde die
forscherin emmanuel chabrier und
jennifer suttner veröffentlichen damals
einen artikel über eine methode mit der
sie jeden beliebigen abschnitt aus einer
dna ausschneiden und ersetzen konnten
christa kassen neuen werkzeug macht sich
einen abwehrmechanismus von bakterien zu
nutzen wenn sie von viren angegriffen
und überleben diese angriff bauen sie
sich teile der viren dna in ihre beta 1
es ist eine erinnerung an diesem
schädling dadurch kann er beim
nächsten mal durch diese gespeicherte
dna eigenschaft also diesen teil aus der
viren dna sofort erkannt und bekämpft
werden
genau diese technik die das zerschneiden
und modifizieren der dna ermöglicht
wird von kurt back up 9 genutzt mit
diesem werkzeug kann jetzt quasi nach
lust und laune in der dna herum
geschnitten und manipuliert werden
stunden ganze topische versuche im gang
in china wird bereits an menschen
experimentiert dabei werden die
immunzellen gezielt verändert so dass
sie bei einem mann mit lungenkrebs
gezielt den tumor attackieren diese
versuche sind aber nicht ohne bei einem
mann mit einer genetischen
lebererkrankungen gegen das in den usa
vor 17 jahren mit einem anderen
verfahren schießt das immunsystem
geriet außer kontrolle und er starb
innerhalb von wenigen tagen
trotzdem setzten die
wissenschaftlerinnen große hoffnung in
chris backus 9
denn eigentlich so biologen kann es
jeder idiot bedienen mit diesem werkzeug
können preiswert und mit geringem
aufwand fällen für die
unterschiedlichsten zwecke manipuliert
werden weil es so einfach ist oder sagen
wir mal für wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen keine große hürde
mehr darstellt haben forscher um serge
shipman von der harvard university jetzt
die dna von escherichia coli
darmbakterien so manipuliert dass sie
dort ein bild von einer hand platzieren
konnten und sogar eine filmsequenz sind
die erste filmsequenz überhaupt wie vor
140 jahren bewies dass pferde beim
galopp zeitweise kein bein mehr am boden
haben das verrückte dabei 90 prozent
der bildinformationen konnten wieder aus
der vene herausgelesen werden dass chris
packard 9 wird risiken wie eine neue
studie herausgefunden hat so exakt wie
bisher gedacht ist das werkzeug gar
nicht gespart neuen verursacht
mutationen auch an anderen stellen des
erbgutes die nicht gewollt um sie
aufzuspüren wurden computer algorithmen
entwickelt die sie vorher sagen
doch die scheinen nur einen bruchteil
dieser veränderung im erbgut zu finden
schäfer von der stanford university und
ihr team
die hat jetzt herausgefunden dass
erhebliche mutation kann ich gefunden
werden für genmanipulation im labor
scheint das verfahren dabei gut zu
funktionieren
bei lebenden organismen aber nicht die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
untersuchen dafür mäuse bei denen
eingehen dass blindheit verursacht
verändert wurde
bei zwei mäusen das team an 1500
stellen im erbgut veränderung bei mehr
als 100 stellen waren es sogar größere
bereiche bei denen das erbgut
ausgetauscht oder gelöscht wurde
dabei warnen die forscherinnen und
forscher dass schon eine einzige
veränderung
große schäden verursachen könnte ihre
empfehlung verbesserung von küster klas
9 und die genaue beobachtung der
veränderung das würde dann auch zur
folge haben dass abgespeicherte filme
deutlich besser aussehen
vielleicht haben wir dann irgendwann
hamster braucht es zu hause in denen
alle spielfilme und serien abgespeichert
sind
die je gedreht wurden niedrigen
datenraten oder ein komplett ausgefallen
setzt können uns dann egal sein aber
vielleicht ist das auch ein bisschen zu
sehr frankenstein was man ihr schreibt
es in die kommentare ich bin auf jeden
fall gespannt und halten euch hier
natürlich auf dem laufenden wenn ihr
kein video verpassen wollt dann wird mir
kein abo aufs auge unvergesslich denen
aus die glocke weiter geht es mit ein
mensch nach maß genmanipulation einfach
draufklicken wenn es euch interessiert
oder ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran